on the eve of the american bicentennial
he urged his countrymen to move in a new
direction
[Applause]
my colleagues of the congress
i have the distinct privilege
and the high personal honor
of presenting to you
the president of the united states
[Applause]
[Music]
mr speaker
mr vice president members of the 94th
congress
and distinguished guests
26 years ago
a freshman congressman
a young fellow
with lots of idealism who was out to
change the world
stood before sam rayburn
in the well of the house
and solemnly swore to the same oath
that all of you took yesterday
an unforgettable experience
and i congratulate you all
two days later
that same freshman stood
at the back of this great chamber
over there someplace
as president truman all charged up by
his single-handed election victory
reported as the constitution requires on
the state of the union
when the bipartisan applause
stopped president truman said
i am happy to report to the 81st
congress that the state of the union is
good
our nation is better able than ever
before to meet the needs of the american
people and to give them
their fair chance in the pursuit of
happiness
it is foremost among the nations of the
world in the search for peace
today
that freshman member from michigan
stands where mr truman stood
and i must say to you
that the state of the union
is not good
millions of americans are out of work
recession and inflation are eroding the
money of millions more
prices are too high and sales are too
slow
this year's federal deficit will be
about 30 billion dollars
next year's probably 45 billion dollars
the national debt
will rise to over 500 billion dollars
our plant capacity and productivity are
not increasing fast enough
we depend on others for essential energy
some people question their government's
ability to make hard decisions and stick
with them
they expect washington politics
as usual
yet
what president truman said on january 5
1949
is even more true in 1906
we are better able to meet our people's
needs
all americans do have a fair chance to
pursue
happiness
not only are we still the foremost
nation in the pursuit of peace
but today's prospects
of attaining it
are infinitely brighter
there were 59 million americans employed
at the start of 1949
now there are more than 85 million
americans who have jobs
in comparable dollars
the average income of the american
family has doubled during the past 26
years
now i want to speak very bluntly
i've got bad news
and i don't expect much
if any applause
the american people want action
and it will take both
the congress
and the president to give them what they
want
[Applause]
progress and solutions can be achieved
and they will be achieved
my message today is not intended to
address all of the complex needs of
america
i will send separate measures
messages making specific recommendations
for domestic legislation
such as the extension of general revenue
sharing and the voting rights act
the moment has come to move in a new
direction
we can do this by fastening a new
partnership between the congress on the
one hand
the white house on the other
and the people
we both represent
let us mobilize the most powerful and
most creative industrial nation that
ever existed on this earth
to put all our people to work
the emphasis on our economic efforts
must now shift
from inflation
to jobs
to bolster business and industry and to
create new jobs
i propose a one-year tax reduction of 16
billion dollars
quarters would go to individuals
and one quarter to promote business
investment
this cash rebate
to individuals amounts to 12 percent of
tax payments
a total cut of 12 billion dollars
with a maximum of one thousand dollars
per return
i call on the congress to act by april
first
if you do
and i hope you will
the treasury can send the first check
for half the rebate in may
in the second by september
the one the other one-fourth of the cut
about four billion dollars will go to
business including farms
to promote expansion and to create more
jobs
the one-year reduction for businesses
would be in the form of a liberalized
investment tax credit
increasing the rate to 12
for all business
this tax cut
does not include the more fundamental
reforms needed in our tax system
but it points us in the right direction
allowing taxpayers rather than the
government
to spend their pay
cutting taxes now
is essential if we are to turn the
economy around
a tax cut
offers the best hope of creating more
jobs
unfortunately it will increase the size
of the budget deficit
therefore
it is more important than ever
that we take steps to control
the growth of federal expenditures
part of our trouble is that we have been
self-indulgent
for decades
we have been voting ever increasing
levels of government benefits
and now the bill
has come due
we have been adding so many new programs
that the size and the growth of the
federal budget has taken on a
life of its own
one characteristic of these programs is
that their cost increases automatically
every year
because the number of people eligible
for most of the benefits
increases every year
when these programs were enacted
there's no dollar amount set
no one knows what they will cost
all we know is
that whatever they cost last year
they will cost more
this year
it's a
simple arithmetic
unless we check the excessive growth of
federal expenditures
or impose on ourselves
matching increases in
we will continue to run huge
inflationary deficits in the federal
budget
if we project
the current
built-in momentum
of federal spending
through the next 15 years
state
federal and local government
expenditures
could easily comprise half
of our gross national product
this compares with less than a third
in nineteen seventy
i've just five
the process of preparing the budget
submissions for fiscal year 1976.
in that budget
i will propose legislation
to
of
re
number of existing programs
i have also concluded that no new
spending programs can be initiated this
year except for energy
[Applause]
further i will not hesitate to veto any
new spending programs adopted by the
congress
[Applause]
as an additional step forward putting
the federal government's
correct
percent
federal paces in 1975
in all government programs tied to the
consumer price index including social
security
civil service and military retirement
pay
and food stamps
i also propose a one-year maximum
increase of five percent
none of these recommended ceiling
limitations over which congress has
final authority
because
says they involve anticipated payments
to many many deserving people
nonetheless it must be done
i must emphasize
that i'm not asking to eliminate to
reduce to freeze these payments
i'm merely recommending
that we slow down the rate at which
these payments increase and these
programs grow
only a reduction in the
growth of spending can keep federal
borrowing down
and reduce the damage to the private
sector from high interest rates
only a reduction in spending can make it
possible
for the federal reserve system
to avoid an inflationary growth in the
money supply
and thus restore balance to our economy
a major reduction in the growth of
federal spending
can help dispel
the uncertainty that so many feel about
our economy and put us on the way to
curing our economic ills
if we don't act
to slow down the rate of increase in
federal spending
the united states treasury
will be legally obligated
to spend more than
360 billion dollars in fiscal year 1976.
even if no new programs are enacted
these are not matters of conjecture or
prediction
but
the size of these numbers and their
implications
for our everyday life and the health of
our economic system
are shocking
i submitted to the last congress a list
of budget deferrals and rescissions
there will be more cuts recommended in
the budget that i'll submit
even so
the level of outlays for fiscal year
1976 is still much much too high not
only
is it too high for this year
but the decisions we make now
will inevitably have a major and growing
impact
on expenditure levels in future years
i think
this is a very fundamental issue
that we
the congress and i
must jointly solve
economic disruptions we and others our
experience
experiencing
stems in part from the fact that the
world price of petroleum has quadrupled
in the last year
but in all honesty
we cannot put all of the blame on the
oil exporting nations
we the united states
are not blameless
our growing dependence upon foreign
sources has been adding to our
vulnerability
for years and years
and we did nothing to prepare ourselves
for such an event
as the embargo of 1973.
during the 1960s
this country had a surplus capacity of
crude oil
which we were able to make available to
our trading partners whenever there was
a disruption of supply
this surplus capacity enabled us to
influence influence both supplies
and prices of crude oil throughout the
world
our excess capacity neutralized
any effort at establishing
an effective cartel
and thus the rest of the world was
assured
of adequate supplies of oil
at reasonable prices
by 1970
our capacity
our surplus capacity had vanished
and as a consequence the latent power of
the oil cartel could emerge in full
force
europe and japan both heavily dependent
on imported oil
now struggle to keep their economics
or economies in balance
even the united states our country
which is far more self-sufficient than
most other industrial countries
has been put under serious pressure
i am proposing
a program which will begin
to restore our country's surplus
capacity
in total energy in this way we will be
able to assure ourselves
reliable
and adequate energy
and help foster
a new world
energy stability for other major
consuming nations
but this nation and in fact the world
must face the prospect of energy
difficulties between now and 1985.
this program will impose burdens
on all of us
with the aim of reducing our consumption
of energy and increasing our production
great attention has been paid
to the considerations of fairness
and i can assure you that the burdens
will not fall
more harshly
on those less able
to bear them
i'm recommending a plan to make us
invulnerable
to cutoffs of foreign oil
it will require sacrifices
but it
and this is most important it will work
i have set the following national energy
goals to assure sure that our future
is as secure and as productive as our
past
first
we must reduce oil imports by 1 million
barrels per day by the end of this year
and by 2 million barrels per day by the
end of 1977.
second
we must end vulnerability
to economic disruption
by foreign suppliers by 1985.
third
we must develop
our energy technology and resources so
that the united states has the ability
to supply a significant share of the
energy needs of the free world
by the end of this century
to attain these objectives
we need immediate action
to cut imports
unfortunately
in the short term there are only a
limited number of actions which can
increase domestic supply
i will press for all of them
i urge
quick action
on the necessary legislation to allow
commercial production at the elks hill
california naval petroleum reserve
[Applause]
in order that we make greater use of
domestic coal resources
i am submitting amendments
to the energy supply and environmental
coordination act
which will greatly increase the number
of power plants that can be promptly
converted to coal
[Applause]
obviously voluntary conservation
continues to be essential but tougher
programs are needed
and needed now
therefore
i am using presidential powers
to raise the fee
on all imported crude oil and petroleum
products
crude oil fee levels
will be increased one dollar per barrel
on february first
by two dollars per barrel on march first
and by three dollars per barrel on april
first
i will take actions
to reduce undue hardships
on any geographical region
before foregoing are interim
administrative actions
they will be rescinded
when the broader but necessary
legislation is enacted
to that end i am requesting the congress
to act within 90 days
on a more comprehensive energy tax
program
it includes
excise taxes and import fees totaling
two dollars per barrel
on product imports and on all crude oil
deregulation of new natural gas
and enactment of a natural
gas excise tax
i plan to take presidential initiative
to decontrol the price
of domestic crude oil
on april 1st
i urge the congress
to enact a windfall profits tax
by that date
to ensure that oil producers
do not profit unduly
[Applause]
the sooner congress acts
the more effective the oil conservation
program will be and the quicker
the federal revenues can be returned to
our people
i am prepared to use presidential
authority to limit imports as necessary
to guarantee success
i want you to know that before deciding
on my energy conservation program
i considered rationing
and higher
gasoline taxes as alternatives
in my judgment
neither would achieve the desired
results
and both would produce unacceptable
inequities
a massive program must be initiated
to increase energy supply to cut demand
and provide new standby emergency
programs
to achieve
the independence
we want by 1985.
the largest part of increased oil
production must come from new frontier
areas
on the outer continental shelf and from
the naval petroleum reserve number four
in alaska
it is the intent of this administration
to move ahead
with exploration leasing and production
on those frontier areas of the outer
continental shelf
where the environmental risks
are acceptable
use of our most abundant domestic
resource coal is severely limited
we must strike a reasonable compromise
on environmental concerns
with coal
i am submitting clean air amendments
which will allow greater coal use
without sacrificing clean air goals
i vetoed the strip mining legislation
passed by the last congress
with appropriate changes
i will sign a rever a revised version
when it comes to the white house
i am proposing a number of actions to
energize our nuclear power program
i will submit legislation to expedite
nuclear leasing
and the rapid selection of sites
in recent months utilities have canceled
or postponed over 60 percent
of planned nuclear expansion and 30
percent
of planned additions to non-nuclear
capacity
finance financing problems for that
industry are worsening i am therefore
recommending
that the one-year investment tax credit
of 12 percent be extended an additional
two years
to specifically
speed the construction
of power plants that do not use natural
gas or oil
i am also submitting proposals for
selective reform of state utility
commission regulations
to provide the critical stability for
our domestic energy production in the
face of world price uncertainty
i will request legislation to authorize
and require
authorize and require tariffs import
quotas or price floors
to protect our energy prices at levels
which will achieve energy independence
increasing energy supplies is not enough
we must take additional steps to cut
long-term consumption
i therefore propose to the congress
legislation
to make thermal efficiency standards
mandatory
for all new buildings in the united
states
a new tax credit of up to one hundred
and fifty dollars for those homeowners
who install
insulation equipment
the establishment of an energy
conservation program
to help low-income families
purchase
insulation supplies
legislation
to modify and defer automotive pollution
standards for five years
which will enable us to improve
automobile gas mileage
by 40 percent by 1980
these proposals and actions
cumulatively
can reduce our dependence on foreign
energy supplies to three to five billion
barrels per day by 1985.
to make the united states invaluable to
foreign disruption
i propose standby emergency legislation
and a strategic
storage program
of 1 billion barrels of oil for domestic
needs
and 300 million barrels
for national defense purposes
i will ask for the funds needed for
energy research and development
activities
i have established a goal of one million
barrels of synthetic fuels in shale oil
production per day
by 1985 together
with an incentive program to achieve it
i have a very deep belief
in america's capabilities
within the next 10 years
my program envisions
200 major nuclear power plants
250 major new coal mines
150 major fired or coal-fired power
plants
30 major new refineries
20 major new synthetic fuel plants the
drilling of many thousands
of new oil wells the insulation of 18
million homes in the manufacturing and
the sale
of millions of new automobiles
trucks and buses
that use much less fuel
[Applause]
i happen to believe that we can do it
in another crisis
the one in 1942
president franklin d roosevelt said this
country would build 60 000 military
aircraft
by 1943
production in that program
had reached
125 000
aircraft annually
they did it then
we can do it now
[Applause]
if the congress and the american people
will work with me to attain these
targets they will be achieved and will
be surpassed
from adversity let us seize opportunity
revenues of some 30 billion dollars from
higher energy taxes designed to
encourage conservation
must be refunded to the american people
in a manner
which corrects distortions in our tax
system
wrought by inflation
people have been pushed into higher tax
brackets by inflation with consequent
reduction in their actual spending power
business taxes are similarly distorted
because inflation
exaggerates reported profits resulting
in excessive taxes
accordingly
i propose that future individual income
taxes be reduced
by sixteen and a half billion dollars
this will be done by raising the low
income allowance and reducing tax rates
this continuing tax cut
will primarily benefit lower and
middle-income taxpayers for example a
typical family of four with a gross
income of five thousand six hundred
dollars
now pays
185 dollars in federal income taxes
under this tax cut plan
they would pay nothing
a family of four with a gross income of
twelve thousand dollars
now pays a
thousand two hundred and sixty dollars
in federal taxes my proposal reduces
that
total by 300
families grossing 20 000 would receive a
reduction of 210 dollars
those with the very lowest
can least afford higher costs
must also be compensated
i propose a payment of eighty dollars to
every person eighteen years of age and
older in that very limited category
state and local governments
will receive two billion dollars
in additional revenue sharing to offset
their increased energy costs
to offset inflationary distortions and
to generate more economic activity
the corporate tax rate
will be reduced from 48
to 42 percent
now let me turn if i might to the
international dimensions of the present
crisis
at no time in our peacetime history
as the state of the nation
depended more heavily on the state of
the world
and seldom if ever
as the state of the world depended more
heavily on the state
of our nation
the economic distress is global
we will not solve it at home unless we
help to remedy the profound economic
dislocation abroad
world trade and monetary structure
provides markets
energy food and vital raw materials for
all nations
this international system is now in
jeopardy
this nation can be proud of significant
achievements in recent years in solving
problems and crises
the berlin agreement the salt agreements
our new relationship with china the
unprecedented efforts in the middle east
are immensely encouraging
but the world is not free from crisis
in a world of 150 nations where nuclear
technology is proliferating
and regional conflicts continue
international security cannot be taken
for granted
so let there be no mistake about it
international cooperation is a vital
factor
of our lives today
this is not a moment
for the american people
to turn inward
more than ever before
our own well-being depends on america's
determination and america's leadership
in the whole wide world
we are a great nation spiritually
politically militarily diplomatically
and economically
america's commitment to international
security
has sustained
the safety of allies and friends in many
areas
in the middle east in europe in asia
our turning away
would unleash
new instabilities
new dangers
around the globe which in turn
would threaten our own security
at the end of world war ii we turned a
similar challenge into an historic
opportunity
and i might add an historic achievement
an old order was in disarray political
and economic institutions were shot
in that period this nation and its
partners built new institutions
new mechanisms of mutual support and
cooperation
today as then
we face an historic opportunity
if we act imaginatively and boldly
as we acted then
this period will in retrospect be seen
as one of the great creative moments
of our nation's history
the whole world is watching
to see how we respond
a resurgent american economy would do
more to restore the confidence of the
world in its own future than anything
else we can do
the program that this congress passes
can demonstrate to the world
that we have started to put our own
house in order
if we can show that this nation is able
and willing to help other nations meet
the common challenge
it can demonstrate that the united
states will fulfill its responsibilities
as a leader
among nations
quite frankly
at stake is the future of industrialized
democracies
which have perceived their destiny in
common
and sustained it in common
for 30 years
the developing nations are also at a
turning point
the poorest nations see their hopes of
feeding their hungry
and developing their societies shattered
by the economic crisis
the long-term economic future for the
producers of raw materials
also depends on cooperative solutions
our relations with the communist
countries are a basic factor of the
world environment
we must seek to build a long-term basis
for coexistence
we will stand by our principles
we will stand by our interests
we will act firmly when challenged
the kind of a world we want
depends on a broad policy of creating
mutual incentives
for restraint
and for cooperation
as we move forward to meet our global
challenges and opportunities we must
have the tools to do the job
our military forces are strong
and ready
this military strength deters aggression
against our allies
stabilizes our relations with former
adversaries
and protects our homeland
fully adequate conventional and
strategic forces cost many many billions
but these dollars are sound insurance
for our safety
and for a more peaceful world
military strength alone is not
sufficient
effective diplomacy is also essential in
preventing conflict and building world
understanding
the vladivostok negotiations with the
soviet union represent a major step
in moderating strategic arms competition
my recent discussions with the leaders
of the atlantic community japan and
south korea
have contributed to meeting
the common challenge
but we have serious problems before us
that require cooperation between the
president
and the congress
by the constitution
and tradition
the execution of foreign policy is the
responsibility of the president
in recent years under the stress of the
vietnam war
legislative restrictions on the
president's ability to execute foreign
policy and military decisions
have proliferated
as a member of the congress
i opposed some
and i approved others
as president
i welcome the advice and cooperation of
the house and the senate
[Applause]
but if our foreign policy is to be
successful
we cannot rigidly restrict in
legislation
the ability of the president to act
the conduct of negotiations
is ill-suited to such limitations
legislative restrictions
intended for the best motives and
purposes
can have the opposite result
as we have seen most recently
in our trade relations with the soviet
union
for my part
i pledge this administration
will act in the closest consultation
with the congress
as we face delicate situations
and troubled times throughout the globe
when i became president only five months
ago i promised the last congress a
policy of communication conciliation
compromise and cooperation
i renew that pledge
to the new members
of this congress
let me sum it up
america needs a new direction which i
have sought to chart here today
a change of course which will
put the unemployed back to work
increase real income and production
restrain the growth of federal
government spending
achieve energy independence
and advance the cause of world
understanding we have the ability
we have the know-how
in partnership with the american people
we will achieve these objectives
as our 200th anniversary approaches we
owe it to ourselves
and to posterity
to rebuild our political and economic
strength
let us
make america
once again
and for centuries more to come
what it has so long been
a stronghold
and a beacon light
of liberty
for the whole world thank you
president ford has just finished his
first state of the union address lasting
41 and a half minutes
and he was absolutely right he got very
little applause during that i think past
presidents have generally managed to
have it as uh as many as 33 breaks for
applause
immediately he's going out now he's
going past senator eastland just behind
him where's the president's hotel in the
senate
you're watching american history tv all
weekend every weekend on c-span 3.
to join the conversation